I have put up in front of you welcoming
slide further tutorial so we have set up
a deployment of desk on binder if you go
to this URL you'll have to type it in
I'm afraid then at that location which
is here you'll see the big launch binder
button if you click on that then after a
certain amount of waiting you will get a
screen that looks something like what
you see in front of you you can be doing
this while I start and explain what's in
this tutorial and what we'll be doing
and about a little bit about desk in
general I'd also like to introduce Jim
Jim also works at anaconda and ask with
me and he'll be handling the second half
of this tutorial and I'll be doing the
first half also I'm told that the Wi-Fi
is not the fastest so please bear with
the system it might take a little while
for things to come up for you did
anybody not get this URL of people still
typing it in I can leave it there for a
few moments longer okay so welcome to
desk how many people here have actually
used desk before I see a smattering of
hands go up so we will start at the
beginning and take you through what ask
is and why you might consider using it
and hopefully at the end of this short
hour-and-a-half period you'll at least
be interested enough to go off and try
things for yourself desk is a your
Python parallel execution engine so it's
a way that you can take the normal
Python based data analyses that you
might already have and scale them out
both on a just a single machine scale
out in the amount of memory that you can
use and using all of the cores on your
machine and as you'll see in the
tutorial itself scaling it too
cluster in the cloud on your company's
deployments or wherever it may be
it's all pure Python it's all pretty
approachable and the whole point of
tasks is to reuse all of the Python
tools that you're familiar with so that
you don't have to learn new stuff people
are still typing can you put your hands
up if some of you have already managed
to get to an interface like this see
that's not bad ok ok so that's to be
expected if you go to the documentation
at this address so I will just search
for desk then there are examples there
there's API reference there's a full set
of everything that you might need
including more tutorials so at the end
of this tutorial if you find that you
want more then that's the place to start
now on the left hand pane here there is
a file selector this might have come up
immediately for you when your interface
starts we will be starting with number 1
if you double click on this then it will
open in one of these tabs like like this
and you can click on the icon here to
get rid of the selector just so you have
more space on your screen for seeing
what you're doing the right-hand panes
here will only come up when we're using
a desk cluster shortly so I'll show you
what those are about in a moment ok so
the first of the two notebooks is to do
with data frames if you don't already
use pandas then this might seem a little
strange to you I'm assuming them most of
you know what pandas is anybody not know
what pandas is anybody too shy to admit
that they don't know what pandas
okay so they'll make this it'll make a
bit more sense if you already use pandas
so task one of the things that it can do
for you is scale out your existing
pandas workflow it does this by having
an API which matches the pandas API and
implements most of the things that you
might do with a panda's data frame so
for example I'm going to go through a
short example here in which we're
actually going to use pandas directly
this is using some data in CSV format
that happens to be on Google Cloud
storage so in a particular public book
it is the the fonts okay by the way yeah
everybody can see that okay in a
particular bucket that's publicly
available there are a bunch of CSV files
this is taxi trip data over a particular
year and there are a few of these files
each of the files is rather large and
this is the kind of work that if you're
using pandas you would be used to you
can open one of these files and you can
read the first 1 million rows in this
case so this is just running in a single
thread in a single container in this
case it takes a little while for this is
basically waiting for download to happen
from the cloud to the client and then to
be passed into a data frame having done
that we have a date data frame now you
see the slowness of the Wi-Fi so it
obviously takes no time to display a
data frame but it does take some time
for all of these values to actually be
rendered within the browser if the Wi-Fi
is slow so we have a load of stuff here
a number of columns and a lot of rows
this is still only a small subset of the
complete data frame and we can do some
normal pandas like things to it so one
of the fields available is passenger
counts we can add up in these 1 million
trips how many passengers were there in
total and it was this number so there
was one point six eight million
passengers okay that makes sense we can
also do some more complex things such as
what's the typical or strictly speaking
the mean trip distance for those rides
that happen to have one passenger
exactly and that is 2.9 miles as I guess
not sure and group I so these are the
kinds of things that people who use
pandas do all the time it's roughly
equivalent to doing similar kinds of
operations in sequel ok now we get to a
little bit of magic
so by executing this particular cell
after the Wi-Fi does its thing
we will have a nice little widgets
appear here that is an interface to a
task cluster running within this
infrastructure wait a moment this will
eventually work for everybody so there
we are we have a cluster and it has 20
workers each of those workers has two
cores and the total amount of memory
available is a hundred and forty
gigabytes
that's quite a lot of memory the
interesting thinking here is how easy it
was to get this up and running so that's
a lot of processing power we we next
make a client to the cluster and that
client is the thing that's going to talk
between the jupiter kernel that's
running here on a particular part with
the rest of the cluster you also see
that these panels on the right hand side
have populated with some stuff if it's
rather empty just for the time being
so lots of times if you want to do
distributed data framework on a cluster
you will do exactly the same thing as
you did for pandas except replace pandas
dataframe commands with desk data frame
commands so that's data frame dot read
CSV looks a lot like the one that we had
before for read CSV except that we
simply give it this URL and ask knows
how to interpret this as being on Google
some passing commands these are the same
kinds of things that you would give to
pandas read CSV one interesting thing is
that you have this wildcard character
tasks will expand this to load all of
the files in one go so when I call this
this has a dot persist here which means
that the cluster will start away
straightaway
loading this data and storing it in
memory and you can see some exciting
things starting to happen on the right
hand side of the screen at the bottom we
have basically a progress bar with three
items here we have the read block which
is get me some bytes we have the read
text which is passed these bytes in to
pandas dataframes and they're going to
be apparently 365 pieces of this and
then from delayed is look at these
blocks of data frame and consider them
as being one giant data frame across the
whole of our cluster see this is working
data is being loaded the time is
dominated by getting these blocks so you
can see the difference you have these
this is a time graph here for all of the
40 cores that we have working these
darker pieces correspond to waiting four
bytes to download from Google and these
slightly lighter green blocks are taking
those and turning them into pandas
dataframes the important thing to
realize here is that it's actually
pandas that's doing the work and asked
is acting as an orchestration engine to
farm out this work across the cluster
and to call
handers on the pieces that we're going
to marshal this may take a while again
there's the Wi-Fi is what the bottleneck
is updating this it should only take a
few minutes for the whole thing to
complete if you're executing cell along
cells along with me then hopefully this
is running for you to put your hands up
please if you have successfully started
a cluster see a number of hands but not
everybody and of those people how many
actually have this running more or less
the same people a few a few not okay so
it will take some time for all of this
to start up part of the time is down to
Google or allotting resources so we have
to wait for all of those to come online
part of the time is just waiting for the
Wi-Fi to catch up so please bear with me
I will continue on the cluster will
remain live at the end of this tutorial
for a while so that you can run through
this in your own time as well okay so we
have this thing that we have called DF
it is a data frame it just happens to be
split into many pieces across the
cluster and we can do data frame like
things to it when we do then it will
operate on the pieces of desk data of
pandas dataframe that are scattered
across the cluster so when we do this OH
actually nothing happened immediately
and this takes us into a slight detour
which is task is lazy by default that is
it will not do work until you explicitly
ask it to do work the way that you ask
it to do work normally is this dot
compute method so we have this thing and
it is a task scalar so desk already
knows that this thing will output a
single number in order to actually get
the value of this and to start things
happening on our cluster we're going to
have to call this
compute method on it so for the first
one of these where passenger count dot
some we already saw this before for the
subset I will actually type this in for
you to show what happens or copy and
paste which is more convenient and now
we have a value you saw again a load of
things happen on the right hand side
I'll show you what that is in a moment
but we have here two hundred and forty
five million passengers and is only
about one passenger and a bit per ride
so that actually roughly reflects the
total number of rows in this dataset
that's quite a lot of data it's not
massively big data but it it's more than
you would conveniently handle on a
single machine now what happened on the
right hand side we have we have some
yellow blocks if i zoom into this block
it's called get length so dusk did some
analysis are the lengths of each of our
data frames it also called some on each
of the pieces of our data frames now you
have a lot of sums on a lot of counts
and this red bit when red shows up it
means that communication is going on so
all of those pieces of length and pieces
of some have been brought to the same
worker so that they could be added
together to make a total length and a
total count and that's how you get the
total sum at the output here it would
also be the kind of thing that you did
for the average and I will give you some
minutes to try the next two little
requests here this will hopefully give
some time further people waiting on
Wi-Fi and Google to catch up in the
meantime you can put your hand up to ask
general questions
why am I here what are we doing at all
and I'll try and answer them all so Jim
is moving around at the back and maybe
some of the people can help with
individual issues if for some reason
your particular interface is not working
have a question I start with the easy
questions yes so the question was what
is the difference between dusk and pi
spark pi spark also has a dataframe
abstraction api which enables you to do
things like this a big part of the
difference is the implementation so pi
spark is built on java whenever you do
something on the Python and it's
translating those into Java commands
that are sent off to jabber workers if
you combine that with a Python function
then that function runs on Python
workers which take the Java data frame
and deserialize it to Python and do
something and then serialize it back
again that can be unpleasant in some
cases if what you're doing fits very
well into a sequel style pure sequel
then spark will likely do a pretty good
job of it and it's a fine solution for
what you're doing however the data frame
abstraction is just one of the things
that Python is that desk does for you
there's a lot more than us can do for
you and we'll get into that particularly
in the second half of this tutorial if
you're already using explicitly pandas
and Python you like Python then it's
also nice to use a framework which is
all Python and the back-end that's
executing the commands is really pandas
so there is no translation layer here
it's just marshaling of which pieces get
executed by pandas on which Weka so the
scaling out should be smoother for that
reason but if you already have working
PI spark
workflow and pipelines then I'm not
going to say that you you were foolish
to use it it obviously has a pretty good
name for a reason there's a question out
there
the question was how mature is dusk
competitor of the paralyzation
regimes and what would auditors think
about it I can't tell you what others
would think because I'm not one and it
would depend on them different companies
and institutes will have their own
policies regarding what they think is
allowed and what isn't dusk has been
around now for a few years and is used
in production at certain locations that
I won't go into
so it's certainly good enough for some
in the Python data ecosystem in general
many open source projects are listed as
alpha or beta but are actually used in
production every day and that includes
tasks so if you use pandas and pandas is
not at version 1 and calls itself beta
then you know it's in the same category
I would say some parallelism frameworks
have been around for an extremely long
time like MP MPI I PI parallel is I
don't know if 10 years old or something
like that and they work fine and they're
well established whether you would call
them production level at the highest
security and monitoring guarantees I I
don't know if that's true for any of
these actually so this is the reason
that some let's say defense oriented
Institute's want to really control
everything about their clusters on the
other hand that makes it really simple
to set up
scratch clusters for investigation
things spin up quickly you can do
interactive work in an isolated piece of
your cluster very easily
could you expand on that okay so the
question is how performance is asked
versus getting a machine that can fit
all of your data so if you can fit all
of your data into a single panda's data
frame and call pandas functions on it
then that will likely be good enough for
you I implanted as fast as it's well
optimized you can get the use of
multiple cores using tasks but ask
always any system like this always comes
with overhead as well exactly how well
the ask will perform versus pandas will
depend on what it is that you're doing
but task handles data that's bigger than
memory and it handles data across a
cluster so for example in this dataset
most of the time is spent waiting for
data to appear from the storage back-end
if you have a single network card that
could be a problem so try it is usually
what it comes down to and we'll have
just the final question so what we
should move on after there is a
centralized scheduler that farms out
work for the workers and the workers are
Python processors that listen to that
scheduler and do work so in that sense
yes there is a common way for these
things to be architected everything's a
Python process though which would be
nice for those that really like Python
which is most of us a conference like
this and you can look at the code and
figure out how it actually does what it
does pretty easily the graphs that
describe what is to be done are
dictionary like things you can view them
as dictionaries if you want to the
communication happens over tornado
there is a single scheduler if your
scheduler goes down then you will lose
it your cluster yes there is some talk
about how to get around that workers can
come and go okay so moving on I will do
the second of these how many people have
caught up how many people are still
waiting for things to happen
a handful okay well I will blame it on
Google and I will blame it on the Wi-Fi
but I assume that you will get some
workers and you will get some
connectivity eventually unless there's
just too many others in the room hitting
the Wi-Fi at once luckily I can still
seem to be live here average trip
distance grouped by passenger counts we
had exactly the same thing above so
actually I should just I can copy it
whatever it was
so the point is that the API is exactly
the same as in pandas except that I do
not compute to actually get an answer
that's of this and you notice how
quickly that happened actually this I
got the answer before the indication
appeared that the cluster was doing work
which is nice but it was under a second
you can do real interactive data
analysis now of course all of the data
is held in memory so this is the next
section if I restart my cluster
eventually these things disappear and I
do this again okay if I'm to do exactly
the same computation before as before
this now is going to take a while the
reason it takes a while is because it
has to load all of the data if I were to
do each of these next computations
and again I will just do the second of
these once the first one has completed
you will notice that it has to load all
of the data each time which is fine if
you can't fit all of your data into
memory but if you want fast processing
for a lot of data being pulled from a
remote source if you can fit it in
memory you will want to fit it in memory
and deciding at what point to persist
your data into memory of your cluster
will have a very large impact on the
performance of all of the operations
that you want to do so there's my son
this is the same number as before and
all of the data have been processed and
this thing has been forgotten again now
I will get a different view of this and
put this here if I execute this again
then we will see a a graphical view of
the task graph being completed where you
see the green ones are waiting so they'd
not be scheduled yet the red ones are
being temporarily held in memory while
they're being processed - we're doing a
group I here so where we're looking for
each of these and doing mini group eyes
and then aggregating them and then doing
aggregations on the aggregations you can
see this is a fairly complicated thing
but the point is that a lot of these
turn blue which is that particular piece
of data has been processed and as soon
as it's processed it's released from
memory so that you don't use up your
clusters memory this is very useful if
you have more data than you have memory
it is what you will want to do but in
other cases where you care more about
performance than you do about memory use
you will do the possess'd which is this
thing so this is what we started off
doing initially and I'm just going to
run it again this is basically loading
all of your data into memory and keeping
hold of it so that they need anything
that you do to it after that point will
be fast
moving on a little into I already said
some of this stuff but in a bit more
detail while that loads a dust dataframe
is a collection of pandas dataframes
each piece is a reference to a different
part of the original data set in this
case some part of a CSV file somewhere
and you have an index exactly what that
index is is another thing to bear in
mind when you want to optimize for
performance if you have an index that
makes sense for your data for example if
you have a time series data set which we
actually do in this case every one of
these rows has an Associated date/time
if you order your data on that column
and you find the start and end of each
of the pieces this is known in in desk
terminology as the divisions then it
becomes much quicker to do things with
that index so for example if you want to
do time based if you want to get a
particular piece of data from a
particular time that's obviously much
faster if you know which of these pieces
to go to if you want to do rolling
aggregation if you want to do resampling
if you want to do group ion month or
something like that then all of those
things will become much much faster if
you nominate the time series column as
being your index so for the time being
when you we just loaded it we have this
index thing that shows up when we
display the data frame just as da by the
way this is showing you the task the
client here doesn't hold this data in
memory it just holds a description of
what the data frame is like so we know
where the column names I would know what
the column types are but we don't see
any data unless we do dot head here to
get the first few rows this thing is our
dash data frame and one of the most
common things that you might do with
dash data frame is map partitions this
basically runs a particular function on
each of the pieces so if I do that then
you will see confirmation they
if the pieces is a pandas dataframe as
promised and there's quite a few of them
now I will set the index so you're used
to setting the index in pandas in - this
has special meaning we're going to do
some shoveling and salting of the data
because the original data was not
already ordered and we're going to find
out the start and stop of each of the
paths that it's made of and see this
requires a certain amount of work you
can see this dense layer here this is a
many-to-many shuffle layer and if you
look at the stream version of this okay
okay is slow I'll wait for this to
finish though
you can see the things that appear down
here are called split group and join so
that is how you find out for each of the
data frame pieces which of the final
database of data frame pieces will it
end up in you split them into those
pieces then you shuffle those bits
around and reassemble them and that gets
me my new data frame so I think this is
about done
the display is taking a little while to
catch up and now I have a data frame
where you see the left-hand column the
index column has been filled in with
time values so these are actual
date/time like things that we can do
daytime like things - if we look at the
first few rows again wait for the
display then we will see that this is
this is a 2015 data and we start the
first view the very first row apparently
somebody took a trip right on stroke of
New Year actually a few people did which
is interesting
and indeed this whole thing has been
sorted if we look at the tail then we
get at the very end of the year so
people it turns out take taxis
immediately before New Year's and
immediately after New Year's and the
divisions look like date time things at
the point of doing this let's shrink
this the point of doing this is that now
we can fetch a particular piece of data
very quickly if we want all of the rides
on a particular day dot compute will
take all of the rows that match this
location and bring them into the clients
for further processing that looks like
that we have this is now a panda's data
frame with which I can do normal pandas
things and there were apparently this
many 400,000 rows on that particular day
or if we want to do explicitly time
series like things to it for example
resample by hour then we can do that too
and these things become a lot faster
after you've done
setting off the index to a date/time
column this is just a a taster a feeling
for all of the things that you can do
with data frames in task I hope you find
that it works more or less like pandas
does everything feels natural not the
complete pandas api has been implemented
but a very good fraction of it has this
now it's downloading the image of this
plot so that might take a little while
although I don't think I executed this
so I'll do that again and now it should
actually appear okay so this is
throughout the whole year but resample
to one hour frequency the average number
of rides and you can see some some very
clear variability there that it's
probably weakens I think this is a map
about what not bouquet so I can't zoom
in on it for you
I'll also close this cuz it's just too
slow that should make the Wi-Fi a
slightly better for everybody else okay
so we've got to the end of the first of
our notebooks there are a couple of
things for you to try and we'll spend
let's see maybe 10 minutes for you to
catch up try these things and we'll have
some question time again now good is
there a way to process unstructured data
using tasks the answer is yes there is
both the delayed mechanism that you will
see for the second half of this tutorial
and there's also another collection
called
task bag which works a lot like tools
and it's a tools if you use those things
before that is you have
list or dict like things and you're
going to iterate over these and do usual
Python like things to them so if you're
used to that functional way of
programming then the desk bag interface
is the one that implements that the
remaining interface that people might be
interested in is the nd array interface
which is does the same thing that the
data frames thing does to pandas the
array interface does to numpy so you can
have a single logical task array that is
actually appointed to lots of numpy
arrays that are either in file somewhere
or are stored in a memory across your
cluster yeah go ahead
sorry I a few of the methods are special
in the it's implicitly going to get you
in memory data so dart head will
straight away get you a small pandas
dataframe without the compute there is
some but let me get it back again
maybe that wasn't a good idea this take
quite help to up here okay I'll cancel
that the short answer is that yes there
is some documentation and there is
actually more webinar style introduction
to what you might do with that if you go
into desk doc pages there are links
there to it it's not as thorough as it
might be the various screens of the
dashboard are relatively new and have
been developed quite heavily over the
last year or so so there is room for
improvement for sure
but there is a lot of information there
to help you understand what's going on
on your cluster both on the overview of
total amounts of memory a view of all
the tasks and where they go the graphs
being processed as you just saw but also
the worker level so you can go to the
individual workers and figure out what
they're doing on a pretty detailed level
it's into the memory of your cluster so
it is possible to get a single machine
with equivalent amounts of memory you
could do that but if you are doing that
then you probably still would want at
least multi-core processing of that data
and you could do that with tasks
so using tasks to compute an in-memory
thing on a single machine with lots of
cause will be roughly equivalent to
doing the same thing on a number of
machines across a cluster on a cluster
communication from one machine to the to
another will be somewhat slower than
from one process to another on a single
machine on the other hand you typically
get a lot more network bandwidth at fair
setting got clusters of many small
machines or small pods in the kubernetes
sense is usually preferred from system
administrators point of view so they
will often already have
for doing this and asking for a single
machine where the hundred terabytes of
RAM is probably not allowed whereas
asking for a hundred terabytes of RAM in
lots of virtual machines is so it may be
a preference and policy thing okay we're
about half way then I will hand over to
Jim for the remainder for those of you
that are making good progress which
might not be so likely given the Wi-Fi
there is a third notebook which gives
you again just a teaser of machine
learning and ask if you are ahead of us
then feel free to go on to that but we
will move to the second notebook and
load it up when we do that please if you
have something running execute this
cluster that close at the end this is to
make sure that you free up the resources
of your workers so that other people can
use them you can also and probably
should shut down your notebook so there
is a tab on the left here the little
running person tells you what's running
so you can click shut down there and
then to open go back to the files and
double-click on delayed and this will
bring up the new tab so I will bring you
back here okay all right a couple things
real quick how many people have not been
able to access the Jupiter lab set up
here show ants are you able to get on it
and you just find that you're sitting in
a Cell and it's just spinning
nothing's running that's accurate okay
so that apparently is due to proxy that
you might have set up on your machine
say that you are using Capital One's
proxy it doesn't like this set up we
found that that works for
deployment on examples org this uses
HTTP this thing we're running out of
here right now doesn't and the proxy
doesn't like that so you could either
find a way to disable this because
you're going through say not Capital
One's Wi-Fi but the guest Wi-Fi and then
you might get things working otherwise
you can go to example set a side org you
will not be able to run these same
things here but at least there's a
couple things you might be able to play
around with well we're talking yeah
anyway I'm going to be talking about
desk delayed so this is another
interface we use in desk so Martin was
showing using - data frame which looks a
lot like pandas data frames but some
workloads people were talking about
custom or non structured data don't fit
within a panda's data frame like
modality there's a nice blog post done
by someone about using - to do credit
modeling so this is you know a highly
non structured process we have lots of
different steps going through this was
the graph that they generated lots of
different workflows going through moving
data around but this was all done with
desk and this code looked fairly snore
--ml for Python it's a lot of loops a
lot of functions but with death delayed
you're able to paralyze this and scale
this out across a cluster or a large
single machine so we're going to talk
about that later
so if everyone can open the delayed
notebook and make sure that you have
shut down the other notebooks
nose so the question was is this the
same delayed notebook that's on example
zested or if you're not able to get
things running in this binder setup it
is not there is a delayed notebook it'll
walk through some of the same
information now and you can follow along
the this these notebooks also can be run
locally so if you wanted to download it
and run it locally
this one doesn't require scaling across
a cluster as much okay so first we're
gonna define a couple functions adding
in a little sleep to make it take some
time we have a function called Inc which
is going to increment a number and a
function call to add which is going to
add two numbers together if we run this
cell here so we're gonna increment one
call it X increment to call it Y add
those two together call it Z it takes
three seconds that's because each of
these functions sleeps for one second if
we were to instead paralyze it with -
delayed so important to ask the -
delayed task dot delayed is a function
decorator so if if you're not familiar
with decorators decorators in Python
look like this so if you put a nap sign
above it this will call that on the
function and then return the output and
name it foo this is the same as if you
were to do
the app sign is just syntactic sugar for
Python anyway - delayed wraps functions
and makes them delayed so normally a
function in Python runs immediately this
makes it run at a later time so here
we're gonna wrap the call to Inc in
displayed and a second call and then
again down here add this looks similar
to the code we have up here we're just
wrapping all the functions in the later
and it runs pretty much instantaneously
this is because we haven't actually done
anything yet so before we were actually
computing it was calling the sleeps now
it's just built of a graph behind the
scenes to actually compute you called
dot compute this is the same as you saw
in the data frame notebook and it's
going to run and it takes two seconds
does anyone have an idea why that might
be true say again yes yeah so what
happened here Z is a delayed object we
can look at the task graph for Z by
calling a dot visualize method and we
can see that yeah Inc one can be called
here and Inc two can be called there and
then we can add them together these two
can be done in parallel because they
don't depend on each other and so as a
desk is scheduling these it can run them
at the same time and speed up your
workflow if you weren't sleeping say
you're doing some complicated math tasks
those would be a run in parallel and
you'd get speed ups across your code
while writing code that still looks like
normal Python see I mean here I have
some questions to consider I'm just
going to talk through this one so what
would happen if the ink and the add
functions didn't include the sleep say
they were doing something else would you
still be able to get parallelism in a
thread pool does anyone have an idea so
it depends python has this thing called
the global interpreter lock the global
interpreter lock means that you can only
do one Python thing at a time in a
single process but a lot of mathematical
libraries in Python
release the interpreter lock so numpy
for a lot of operations releases the
lock and so you can paralyze an empire
code but generic Python so you working
with strings doing things you might not
be able to get actual parallelism in
this case the sleep call releases the
interpreter lock and you can do multiple
things at once if people have used
number before show of hands who's heard
of number or use number excellent
so number is for those that don't know
number is a another library for speeding
up Python it compiles it down to a
native code you just decorate functions
that look like normal Python and it'll
run them faster but one of the options
you can add is an O'Gill decorator and
so you can say I want to compile my
function with number and I want to
release to go or the interpret
interpreter lock and then that'll run in
parallel and so number and ask play
really well together when you're
building up these custom workflows you
can get true parallelism by writing your
fast code in number and then scheduling
it with desk to run parallel anyway
moving on we have an exercise here we're
going to paralyze a for loop so we have
some data we are going to loop through
the data we're an increment each result
or each number we're going to save it in
a results list and then we're going to
sum the results together so if I do this
I have to defined data first it's gonna
take sequentially so each of these calls
to Inc is gonna happen sequentially and
so that's gonna take what eight seconds
about yeah eight seconds on the money
you can see what the total is so your
job here is to paralyze this you're
gonna put - delayed somewhere within
this loop maybe a couple spots and
you're gonna find a way to paralyze this
so that it doesn't run in eight seconds
it runs faster and will give you about
five minutes or so to work that through
so the question is can you explain why
or what a dowsing is doing behind the
scenes when scheduling these so tasks
has a couple different schedulers so in
this case we're running with the default
scheduler which is threading uses the
local threaded scheduler
there's the distributed scheduler which
is what you saw in the last notebook we
have one that uses multi processing that
we don't recommend people use anymore
it's not as efficient as the distributed
scheduler the distributed scheduler is a
bit of a misnomer it runs perfectly fine
in a local machine and it's easy to
startup so we recommend either using the
threading one or the sure to schedule
there depending on your workflow so the
distribute scheduler can have multiple
process workers and each may have a
thread pool within and you can you can
say how many threads you want per worker
and how many workers you want per
cluster and so it's you can have a
balance between getting true parallelism
because of using multiple processes and
efficiency of shared memory by using
multiple threads
usually we recommend a mix yes yeah yeah
so depending on what year can you
explain again what you may know that
so because things are happening in
threads you have to deal with normal
performance issues for threats so are
you going to have more threads than
course in your cpu are you going to be
doing IO bound work where you might want
to over saturate a worker I think it
really depends on your workflow the
scheduler doesn't do anything in smart
knowing if something is i/o bound or CPU
bound
show of hands who has a solution to this
exercise done already would anyone like
more time like a minute or two more okay
we'll give you about a minute more
all right we're gonna move on so there's
a couple different ways you can actually
paralyze this here is one example so in
this case we have the same results lists
that we're saving we wrap the call to
increment in delayed to delay that call
and then we wrap the call to sum in
Adelaide to delay that call gonna run
that and if we were actually time that
that would take about a second yep
because we have eight threads and we are
computing eight things in parallel did
anyone not wrap some into later well you
didn't did the graph here let's let's
see what do they call this so right now
we have the result this is our delayed
no total that's what I'm looking for so
here's the existing graph if I visualize
that you can see it's running eight
different increment calls all those can
be done in parallel and then we have a
single sum call here if I instead remove
the wrapping of delayed around some so
we're still delaying the increment calls
but not the call to some I can visualize
that and we get this nice fun tall graph
so what's happening here is that delayed
objects implement a lot of pythons
normal operators so you can add them
together like here's total I can do
total plus one it will give me a new
delayed object and then the sum function
in Python just adds them together by
using the addition operator and so you
get this nice big chain this is way less
efficient than actually wrapping it but
you can see that there's a couple
different ways you can actually paralyze
your code this still runs in parallel we
just end up with a lot more tasks that
we need to alright
if you are running in this example on a
binder you can start a communities
cluster here we're gonna be doing some
stuff that will require distributed some
of this might run fine if you're running
locally if you've had to download the
notebooks due to Wi-Fi issues so I'm
going to spin up a quick cluster again
make sure that you have already shut
down your previous cluster if you
haven't already otherwise you're not
gonna have resources
and connect cool so we have another
exercise here we're gonna be paralyzing
a for-loop with control flow this timer
to be running on a distributed scheduler
not on the local scheduler we have a
function called Inc a function called
double and a function called is even
which says if the number is even we're
going to loop through the same data if
it's even we're gonna double it if it's
odd that we're gonna increment it and
they're going to take us some of the
total results your objective here again
is to paralyze this code so sequentially
we're looping through all the data and
doing an operation each time this should
be paralyzing you're going to want to
wrap some of these functions in delay
two but not all of them you have to
figure out exactly where it makes sense
to do that and we'll give you about
three minutes just
alright let's walk through the solution
here so in this case we don't delay the
is even call we want to do that at
runtime but we will delay the calls to
double an ink and some the reason we
don't want to delay is even is because
well here let's see what happens if we
do it so here we can compute and we can
take a look at what the graph looks like
so we each have one double ink double
ink every other number and then we sum
the results together if we ramp is even
in delayed we read a nice error
truth of delayed objects is not
supported the reason is we don't know
what the value is when we're building
this graph we don't know what X is
exactly when it's being built it could
be even it could be odd we don't
actually know what the result is at that
time we'd like to do that at build time
and we can't if we delay it we won't
know you can't compute sorry given a
certain delayed object say total we
don't know if it's true or not unless we
compute it it's what I'm trying to say
which is why you get this error all
right our final example here we're going
to be walking through some data frame
competitions so when we're using data
frame task is building up these graphs
behind the scene for you when using -
delayed you're building up the graphs
manually you can do the same algorithms
using das delayed you just have to
manually write them out so we're gonna
be walking through one of the examples
that you did in the date of here
notebook but building it out using desta
late and seeing what the functions
you're composing or doing so Arcadia in
cloud using GCS we can load that with PI
RL which is a great library
for reading various different file
formats it's gonna take a second so same
data you were looking at before and so
we're gonna be building up this
computation that you could write using
des data frame using desolated instead
so we want to figure out what the mean
passenger count is for all of the files
that match this collab so we have a
couple functions here one that loads a
file into a panda's data frame and then
we can loop through and we can say here
we're gonna load our pandas a two frame
we're gonna take the passenger count and
row to compute its sum
we're gonna take the passenger count
column and we're gonna figure out how
many numbers there are in it and we'll
save both those results and at the end
we will sum all the sums together sum
all the counts together and then divide
the sums by the counts to compute the
mean so this is what you would do this
is what doubts could do behind the
scenes if you actually wrote out this
code using data frame but instead you're
composing together to these functions so
I can run this sequentially but it would
be good to paralyze it because each of
these files can be read in parallel and
the mean of the sums and the counts can
be commuted in parallel and then you can
Ariat them together finally so your job
is to figure out where in this manually
written serial code you want to add it
delayed a decorator to paralyze it I'm
gonna give you about a minute or two to
do that
[Music]
all right by a show of hands how many
people have a solution at this point how
many people would like a minute or two
more time no one I guess we'll move on
them cool so walking through this what
do I need to delay so we define a
function up here we loop through do I
want to delay this function yes yeah way
do I want to make sure that the file
name or files are loaded at a compute
time not at graph build time what about
this do I need to do anything here No
so tasks delayed objects implement
methods so if you just have a delayed
object you can call what other method on
it you want
[Music]
[Music]
so here it's it's a automatically using
the list count method just by calling it
alright how about this
joining to anything here no same thing
it'll automatically use the method in
the attributes on the delayed object and
at runtime they'll be used on the
computed thing appending to some same
thing it's fine
same with counts do I need to delay the
call to some yep and we'll also do it
here how about this yeah I don't need to
do anything with the division here that
will just automatically work as I said
before - too late objects implement a
lot of the operators and so that should
just work so if we run that we get mean
which is a delayed object and I can
compute it and that should run in
parallel
and here we can see the big graph we've
actually generated loading a file doing
some getting attributes count operations
some operations and then finally
aggregating things together so for a bit
of motivation that's the last of our
exercises but we have a third notebook
here which I'm just gonna walk through
this is doing a grid search with
oscillator so we have a library called
desk ml which does a lot of scikit-learn
stuff using tasks you'll paralyze things
it will scale them out across a cluster
one of the things we implement there is
a grid search for people that aren't
familiar grid search is taking a bunch
of different parameters and trying to
figure out what of those parameters give
the model that you're fitting the best
score for some metric that can all be
done in parallel that's fitting a bunch
of different models and then comparing
the results desc uses desolated to build
up these operations in parallel so that
you can have your grid search operation
scale across a cluster and complete a
lot faster I'm actually not gonna run
any of this never mind but that's a
library that exists we found that
desolated is very useful for paralyzing
existing code so we've used it to add
tasks to other libraries a teapot I
think was one that was added recently we
desk can now be used by teapot
optionally to ask ml paralyze the
scikit-learn what else uses it
psychic image now uses desc internally
for some things to paralyze out so it's
a good way to take existing code you
might have written and try to figure out
a way that you can scale it at this
point we have time for questions if
anyone has questions
no she's I don't know how to do there we
go I'm just wondering if you can query
the status of a future that's the late
thing to see if it's done or not like
what it whether it's waiting or being
computed or done so the question is how
can you monitor computations as they're
going through so désolée just builds up
graphs behind the scene the same as
dataframe does your task array or the
other collections that we have the ways
you can monitor them is through the
dashboard so here we did you can see our
file name - data frame computation as
it's moving through this runs in real
time this is the best way that we have
for you to see what's going on there is
no way to query the status on an object
but you can watch as your tasks progress
through did answer your question anyone
else sorry say again um if the taskbar
goes red and stays there for a while and
just never comes back would it kill it
and retry so so the red tasks in the
task stream are data communication is
that what you're asking about okay so
the general question I guess would be
will tasks ever retry computations if
something goes wrong so there's a couple
answers to that say you have a function
that you've written in scythe on or some
low-level language that can cause seg
faults and that function is bad desk
will run it if you paralyze the cross
and if it kills the worker like if the
process seg faults it'll try it again on
another worker and it has a certain
limit before it says no I don't trust
this anymore I don't think this function
is good and then it'll just kill the
whole process it'll say no your your
code is bad to go fix this but if there
are periodic failure
say that you have a function that uses
too much memory and the OS kills it
it'll might try to get on a different
machine I saw in the documentation for a
desk kubernetes you have this adapt
function and it seems like it can
dynamically adjust the size of a cluster
could you explain a little bit how it
makes those decisions I'm like when the
scale-up nodes yeah so we have a couple
different deployment platforms this one
we're using is kubernetes we also have
ones for deploying on yarn so if you
have an existing hadoop cluster you can
deploy tasks on that we have one for
deploying on traditional
high-performance computing clusters
using job queue type things and all of
these follow the same interface where
you have an adapted in a scale method so
let's go back let's see somewhere in
here I have a cluster object yeah
so on the cluster object we have a scale
method where I can set exactly how many
workers I have this is just a nice GUI
for doing the same thing and then we
have adaptive scaling where I can set a
minimum and a maximum number of workers
and it will scale your cluster smaller
or bigger depending on the amount of
work that's going on that algorithm that
we use to determine that how many
workers you might need when you'd want
to scale up when you'd want to slow down
ramping up has changed a couple times
but it's it's based basically on the
amount of memory that is being used by
computations and the amount of CPUs that
you're currently using are is your
cluster flooded with too many tasks and
would adding additional workers help you
paralyze things more or are there a lot
of idle workers sitting around doing
nothing and it wants to scale down
anyone else ok well uh sorry I'm sorry I
can't I didn't hear that do you guys
plan to expand support into deep
learning libraries like for instance
tensorflow so we have a project called
desk tensorflow
which i believe is now part of the
overarching task ml thing so that will
spin up a distributed tensorflow cluster
on your workers you can view some types
of flow computations and spin it down in
general things like that would be best
influenced by people that have ideas for
how they might want to do this we found
that it's very things work well when
there's an existing community of users
that would like to paralyze things out
and they can say what they like to do
and we can help them figure out a way to
do it so if you're someone that uses
distributed tensorflow and you might be
interested in figuring out a way to have
desks do that for you generally working
with people that are domain experts in
the field they're working in say machine
learning and someone from the desk
organization they knows how to paralyze
it we can get a nice library worked out
but there is existing some support for
tensorflow there's extra boost which is
not deeply amenity machine learning same
thing we can spin up an extra Beus
cluster and the desk ml or
probably a couple different issues
around other things in a question
regarding if I have a one big server
what way cell can speed up the current
code if I have enough memory but and I
have multiple cores let's say mm-hmm
forever the question was how can if you
have one big server with how would you
use desk on it yeah so in that case I'm
going to kill this just a free up
resources so the client object right
here if I just call cluster or if I can
spell that'll spin up a local cluster
just on your machine and so that's
that's the recommended way for you're
running multiple processes on a single
machine and you can specify a number of
threads and numbers of workers in that
call but that will spin up local
clusters so let's see what we have here
no so so here we can see I have 16
workers running on 16 course and about
64 gay-rights that's just what's on this
machine the thing my jupiter notebook is
running on this starts up a local
distributing scheduler so it's the same
as if you're running across multiple
machines but it's just using processes
on a single machine
[Music]
okay is ml desk up to date with the
current scikit-learn implementations of
the functions so desk email doesn't try
to imitate scikit-learn we don't
implement all of the algorithms we
implement ones where it makes sense we
have some things for doing model level
parallelism like grid search and some
things for doing a data level
parallelism I don't know exactly what
estimators they're implemented at this
point but there's some that will mimic
the scikit-learn API for doing fit and
predict it works with the latest
scikit-learn but we don't we don't mimic
the interface exactly that was your
question yeah it was mostly about just
is it gonna do the same well I get the
same result it'll just be faster that's
essentially my question faster or works
with larger data is the goal okay thanks
[Music]
hi can I use that for parallel i/o I
want to download big file can I paddle
it yeah you could use that for if you're
just downloading files there might be a
better tools for doing that but it's
still weird work okay so we will be
around all weekend if you're attending
it the rest of the conference and please
feel free to stop us ask questions
otherwise we are always looking for
contributors if you would like to start
helping out and ask if you are part of
an existing community of users of you
know some field and would like to figure
out a way to use to ask to paralyse that
we'd be happy to talk to you thank you
I just wanted to say that Jim is giving
a talk about skåne which is the yarn
integration method of Python which is
capable of deploying tasks on yarn if
that's a buy yarn I mean Hadoop if you
don't know what that is and I'll be
giving a talk on intake which is
slightly related more about how you get
to your data how you catalog what data
sources you have
[Music]
[Applause]